the piece that i published on natural
selections on my substance this week
is about what is wrong with higher ed
and
i talk a lot about the problems with how
science is funded and what it has meant
to how you know how good scientists are
what they do and also then how the most
ambitious scientists are basically
whisked away from the teaching and
governance part of universities
uh but the excerpt that i specifically
wanted there's two excerpts that i want
to share one of them is apropos what you
are talking about brett
i will start by yep here we go so it's
higher ed needs a reboot but being
anti-woke won't be sufficient uh and
it's it's a long piece and i'll actually
be reading this aloud
for everyone for my uh tuesday post this
week
but i'm going to start right now with a
just a
small excerpt from the very end of the
section sorry i'm making people probably
dizzy how science is funded i was going
to read this whole section but uh not
going to and then read the woke
revolution
if we are to be free
we need the scientific process to be
free instead money is driving what
questions get asked as a result some
research that passes for science is not
worthy of the name and other research
which would be science had been allowed
to happen never gets done
this is perhaps the largest problem of
all at modern universities
the woke revolution
into this environment arrived in
ideology which quickly became so widely
adopted that it can now justly be called
a revolution
as science and scientists were being
bought by market forces the door was
left open for more patently craven forms
of anti-intellectualism
flying under the beautiful sounding
banner of social justice embodied by
growing legions of diversity equity and
inclusion officers and administrators it
is most succinctly called woke
what social justice aspires to or claims
to aspire to is the adoption of policies
that recognize past and ongoing bias in
society
reduces such bias going forward and
helps those who have been negatively
affected by it
in practice though it is authoritarian
dogmatic illiberal and mean
as linguist john mcwhorter writes in his
new book woke racism how a new religion
has betrayed black america this ideology
directly blocks the ability of people
who adhere to it from getting ahead
of the movement's three key words
diversity equity and inclusion only one
is an accurate representation of what
the movement stands for the woke do not
embrace or pursue diversity they are on
a mission to reduce human experience and
thought to a single note one one that
agrees with the conclusions that they
have already arrived at
and the woke are not inclusive indeed
they would exclude all those who
disagree with them to the point of
de-platforming and preventing dissenters
from speaking the movement that claims
to advocate for diversity equity
inclusion is therefore both
anti-diversity and exclusionary
what may be surprising to those not
already immersed in this landscape
however is that the woke revolution
really is about equity the disconnect is
that equity doesn't mean what you
probably think it means
the concept of equity has been around
since at least 1981 when it was included
in the first principles of the american
society for public administration the
aspa had this to say about a key
distinction equality they defined as
citizen a being equal to citizen b
equity they defined as adjusting shares
so that citizen a is made equal with
citizen b
many people though when they hear the
word equity synonymize it with equality
we 21st century weird people broadly
nearly universally value equality we are
all equal under the law and we ought to
defend that fiercely equality refers to
having a quality of opportunity equity
in direct contrast promotes equality of
outcome this is a dystopian idea that
was brilliantly satirized in vonnegut's
short story harrison bergeron wherein
those with greater ability are
handicapped in order to bring society
into full compliance then here's this
just the first paragraph of harrison
bergeron
a very short short story worth everyone
reading it
the year was 2081 and everybody was
finally equal they weren't only equal
before god and the law they were equal
every which way
nobody was smarter than anybody else
nobody was better looking than anybody
else nobody was stronger or quicker than
anybody else
all this equality was due to the 211th
212th and 213th amendments to the
constitution and the unceasing vigilance
of agents of the united states
handicapper general
so
this is absolutely apropos a discussion
of uh medically awoke
right i mean we are
this is the same kind of process as you
were pointing out you say on twitter
this morning what i've heard you pointed
out elsewhere
yeah it is the same kind of i mean it's
uncanny how much the same kind of
process it is and you know we have been
on the wrong end of it twice now in two
very different contexts and so it's just
like
you can see that it's the same okay but
i'm playing the interviewer here now
aren't you just looking for trouble
though aren't you just interested in
conflict
no i would say i believe the actual
diagnosis is
um
[Music]
a bit insensitive to social signals or
indifferent to them in some sense and so
i think the point is if you're sensitive
at a normal level
you get
don't go their girlfriend away from the
dangerous thing right and it doesn't
work for everybody on every topic but if
your point is
actually i don't speak that language i
don't know what don't go their
girlfriend means
right and you just keep pursuing things
then what you keep finding is the devil
on our shoulder is you're not the boss
of me
right but the point is you will keep
discovering the delta between the
official story and what you can deduce
if you do your own work and the problem
is if that delta is small it's not a big
deal if it the delta is big
then you just keep discovering this
chasm and you're like the idiot who
doesn't get the message that pointing
that out is bad for you right yeah still
naked guys the emperor is still naked
still naked right it's a different
emperor
really are you sure because it kind of
looks like the same guy because i saw
him naked before he's still there still
no clothes still dresses to the right
um yeah so
anyway it's it it's a fascinating social
process and um
one that i i will say i've had the sense
at the beginning of this last week
this last week okay yeah i mean it was
an increasing sense over time that
enough people around the world were
waking up to what was happening
that it was like
reason was returning
right and i fear
that new variant you know
is
hide under your bed right this isn't the
great reset this is a
you know this is there was some process
running in the computer that the owner
of the computer was displeased by and
they couldn't figure out how to turn it
off so they've unplugged it
and you know now
everything is new again as it were um
[Music]
it's it's the new reset it's the new
reset yeah
and you exactly um well i hope you're
wrong i i you know obviously obviously i
hope you're wrong in this case and you
know we have hoped we were wrong in many
cases um
and uh unfortunately the things that we
have hoped we were wrong about uh we
haven't
for the most part with you know trivial
examples i'm sure but um seeing the
evidence that that has been the case yes
now i will just say one last thing um
that harrison bergeron thing
it has a particular relevance in our
story actually relative to our encounter
with woke one yeah right which was that
as evergreen melted down around us
a student of mine a current student of
mine who had been in the class current
then yeah had been in the class in which
i had put the model for witch hunts and
how they work up on the board somebody
who was watching this happen in real
time
a black woman
took me aside as
protests and everything else was going
on
and she said you have to read this story
harrison bergeron is like
less time for reading stories this week
than ever before in my life and she's
like no
you have to read this story right and
she ultimately did persuade me even then
to read the thing it was like
okay
very interesting yeah um
yeah so that yeah that's that's that's
right it is i mean
too bad we don't have kurt vonnegut
anymore
his his take would be very interesting
if only he had written things that we
could return to um but we do and you
know i have yet to read anything of his
that i didn't find deeply valuable but
you know a link to an online version of
the story is in my piece here so you can
find it there
[Music]